monsieur vous êtes chez moi chez vous et
vous le savez mercier mais permettez-moi
monsieur d'être dépités
je vous permets mais dépêchez vous faute
avouée est à moitié pardonnée n'est ce
pas c'est pas moi qui veux dire le
contraire jacques est alors le guy
mardel que vous prétendez recevoir ce
soir jeunes affirme-t-il pas haut et
fort qu'il n'avoue jamais
j'attends vos explications monsieur
[Musique]
15 mai
jamais jamais baboo jamais
m je n'ai jamais non jamais baboo jamais
que
si tu veux qu'on te tonnes jeu que tu
latin
si tu veux que l'automne
et le bouquet printemps
celui qui déroute et souvient totaux jeu
qui faut semer le dos de bricoles
la ville
jamais
jamais jamais
[Musique]
non jamais jamais
non jamais ben vous jamais que
cette union se défendre tout venant
si tu tiens entendre les plus tendres
celui que l'on aime
bon ok
qu'ils commencent à forest
à
fini tard là
t'as jamais
jamais jamais
ou jamais que l'hiver n'a jamais jamais
jamais ben vous jamais que
il est
non
jamais
jamais ben vous ramène que
il a
je n'ai jamais jamais jamais là vous
jamais que tu là
c'est lourd à porter c'est lourd c'est
encadré cette chanson des marnaises dès
1965 1966 oui c'est une volière qui a
écrit cette chanson je l'écris tu
j'écris la musique qui se croisent de
rhodes qui écrit les paroles
françoise doha way back grande françoise
dorin goian et cette année là un beau
doublé parce qu'elle ait fait n'avoue
jamais et que c'est reason ici pour
réserver et la création s'est passé
comment certes a fait la musique toi
d'abord et ensuite lui a apporté la
musique non non non c'est à dire que moi
je serais je travaille avec des auteurs
que
que paul lederman qui était mon
imprésario de 7 et paul lederman
d'accord trouvé un peu faible et il
voulait que je travaille avec des
personnes et il m'a dit il ya une nana
qui fait des taxes de tant de chansons
qui devraient aller la voir et je suis
allé la voir
et a priori elle était aussi intimidé
que moi et elle m'a donné un certain
nombre de tests en disant voilà j'ai des
textes que j'ai déjà écrit la musique de
ce si vous voulez prendre
et puis j'en ai pris 34 supporter merci
madame j'avais 19 ans et puisque en fac
de droit
et puis je suis gémissait texture mon
piano et puis et c'était c'est à peu
près trois quatre mois avant lui
les examens de fin d'année et de temps
en temps quand entre deux cours de droit
civil mercian je mettais devant le piano
et puis un jour je tombe sur ce texte
je crois que la chanson mais il restait
dix quinze jours sur sur ce piano comme
ça je regarde déjà vers texan est au
bout de
un quart d'heure vingt minutes ce jour
là la chanson était fini et j'ai senti
que j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque
chose inspiration ouais mais c'est sorti
comme ça j'ai appelé françois l écouter
la chanson de vie aussi bien
bah oui c'est bien et puis et oui mais
avant même avant qu'un tube sur les
petits bonds cgem non c'est pas ça m'a
vendu combien en parlant de tubes en
tout parce que maintenant ça continue
avant même que l'on doit être autres
millions 10,3 millions de disques
sais tu te rapporter un maximum et matt
a commencé à avoir cette idée comme ça
de d'écrire des chansons qu'en dehors 18
19 ans pas avant
non non tu étais petit bain donc j'avais
fait toucher les parents quand ils quand
il comptait tout petits une tête qui te
colle un violon dans l'est dans l'est
dans les mains il monfils traviole
hanister médecins surtout les parents
pieds noirs principales violoniste et
médecins la jouer du violon il sera
médecin
en fait j'ai pas été verni parce que
j'ai car c'est là le violon je ne
pouvais pas supporter certains
instruments et puis donc je me suis mis
à faire du piano
solfège est ce que ta mère était
contente au moins ouais mais on était
content une condition c'est que je
finisse mes études
vous ne voulez pas que j'arrête donc
j'ai promis ça j'ai tenu ma fait partie
d après quand tu as fait n'est jamais
tout ça il s'est contenté et après
n'avoue jamais t'as fait quoi alors il
ya eu tous pendant trois ans des
tournées en france avec le françois
et puis après j'ai eu la chance comme on
le sait en france et quatre ans soit
arrêtée en août et on aime ça se passe
et comment alors je crois que j'étais le
seul dans les tournées avec le club qui
me seul qui ne soit pas engueulé avec
lui parce que moi j'étais un petit peu
aussi en moi il fallait que je finisse
ma licence donc quand j'étais dans l'est
dans l'année dans l'est l'autre dans la
loge dans les coulisses moi je faisais
mais vous mettez des de droit à l'abri
j'avais pas trop l'occasion m'engueuler
20 heures après donc ton avec claude
françois et après après comme je vais
représenter la france à l'eurovision
pour m'a demandé de représenter leur
prend 30 octobre concours internationaux
alors j'ai fais le
j'ai représenté la france au festival de
barcelone chanson française de la
chanson à barcelone j'ai gagné j'ai fait
le festival de rio que j'ai gagné
également festival de tokyo
j'ai vu un prix de la critique et tout
ça ça m'a fait faire beaucoup beaucoup
de tournées pendant trois quatre ans à
l'étranger
oui mais c'est vrai ça parce que tu sais
que les chanteurs ils disent toujours
c'est moi je vends beaucoup au japon
c'est vrai toi c'est pas non c'est vrai
que les chanteurs d'ici là mais c'est
vrai quoi c'est vrai je te montrerai les
coupures de pub en écoutant on te croit
mais alors après tu es revenu en france
après tout ces tournées à l'étranger et
on s'est tous dit oui c'est ça à la rue
et si vous ferme ça non parce que je
savais que de toute façon ça se
passerait comme ça et j'ai comme j'ai
toujours eu une position vis-à-vis du
métier qui est malheureusement le ce
métier devenu un métier de hulu les
rapports de force sont très grands et
calmement c'est dans les années soixante
dix et c'est devenu de plus en plus si
au fil des années et maintenant c'est
carrément un rapport de mendiants on est
on est des gouvernements des mendiants
lorsqu'un journaliste et se jouer c'est
réussir ma vie c'est pas si longtemps le
showbiz n'est donc je pars contre
chanter pour moi c'est un besoin vital
je dirais pas que c'est un truc qu'on
dit quand on n'a pas réussi ça je
voulais réussir ma vie
non parce que moi j'ai décidé de réussir
ma vie avant de penser à réussir dans la
chanson dont les problèmes ne soit posée
puisque j'ai managé magma vie rentrer en
fonction de ça plus que j'aurais pu
venir en revenir en france et ramé comme
les autres copains sortir des disques
moi j'ai pratiquement jamais sorti le
disque qui n'a pas marché mais ça fait
sept ans que j'ai pas fait de disque
donc on peut pas dire
marre des laramée pourrait faire début
ça marchait plus non ça marche pas parce
que parce que je sortais de 10 mois mais
a admis allez allez mais à l'époque
à l'époque j'ai
deuxième chance après les rencontres et
françoise le rail jamais c'est que j'ai
rencontré des gens de télé dont certains
savais que j'étais très créateurs et que
je que je pouvait interférer lâché
véritable salle guy lux à boussac
drucker non non non pendant pendant
quatre ans donc j'ai fait de la télé
mais je produis que c'est un but
l'émission de télé et j'ai produit dans
des émissions dès samedi après midi que
le chat potté du luxe mais j'étais
producteur de mes émissions
j'ai produit d
des émissions sur l'a2 à 20h30 avec
annie cordy etc
et puis la dernière mission g est
produite c'était une émission qui
s'appelle sport en fête une vérité mon
présentateur ah ben ouais cette fois
qu'elle va trouver michel volcker non
c'est michel qui m'a téléphoné pour me
dire j'aime bien ton émission j'ai envie
d'y rentrer ah ouais à il est rentré et
moi j'en suis sorti l'allemagne
il a demandé il ya pris la suite de
l'émission il ya beaucoup de talent et
je lui en veux plus donc michel larqué
l'émission moi je me suis retrouvé à la
rue j'avais deux enfants en bas âge il
fallait bien que je fasse quelque chose
donc je refais du disque tient les brawn
gp shine et leur après tu as fait un duo
avec chantal goya c'est moins drôle
c'est quand même parfois que l'on sait
pas peut-être s'était pas lancé c'est
pas la chose la plus fantastique que
j'ai fait est ce que tu penses que toute
cette époque c'est des tentatives de
come back qui ont un peu échoué ou tu
faisais ça comme ça un peu sur le côté
quoi sens
non c'est à dire que je si si pour moi
il était question de dire 'est-ce que tu
préfère ne pas vendre que de vendre des
millions de disques je dis je préfère
vendre des millions de disques c'est
évident et je les ai pas vendu mais je
les ai pas rendu pour quelles raisons
c'est que je n'ai jamais voulu nous
compromettre ou compromettre mon moi
intime c'est à dire que je juge que je
veux bien aller jusqu'à un certain point
les mains nues mais pas me regarder dans
une glace et me dire tu es minable
surtout là parce que c'est pas toi mais
qu'est ce que t'es pas prêt à faire
alors présente dans ce métier qu'est ce
que tu es pas prêt à faire soit entendre
on dirait quand même que c'est une
prostitution perpétuelle
qu'est-ce que tu n'es pas prêt à
demander aux attachés de presse ouais
c'est pas les artistes et appelle les
présentateurs ou les et producteur de
télévision s'est attaché de presse
oui c'est abb prenait l'eau dans votre
édition ne déroge pas à sa non mais
c'est à dire que c'est parce que le à
une certaine époque j'ai produit
d'autres chanteurs il est donc je me
suis retrouvé comme
ah oui quand tu es devenu producteur
s'était énervé savait et demander quoi
donc j'étais bien obligé de défendre des
gens c'est plus facile de défendre
d'autres chanteurs et se défendre soi
même qu'à ce moment là tu vas arrêter
d'être producteur derniers disent que
j'ai produit j'ai dit que j'avais été
remonté un peu au dessus du lot enfin
une entreprise de gravure de disques a
très bien marché entre 80 et 85
s'appelait master one c'est ça y est tu
gagnes de l'argent quand même non
l'action gagne de l'argent finalement tu
graver des disques en vinyle et puis
quand le laser est arrivé tu avais soit
le choix d'investir énormément soin de
laisser tomber tu as laissé tomber est
reparti vers de jouer parce que c'est le
challenge pour moi était réussie donc je
passais à autre chose et j'ai j'avais
quand même à cette époque là où de
nouveaux gros noms très très envie de
chanter
ouais alors comme j'avais plus de dix
qui ont un marché en phase iib opus plus
la rochère n'avoue jamais c'est
introuvable d'ailleurs c'est cher non
elle ressortie à bord oui oui mais enfin
parce que les compilations dirait que ça
qui marche en ce moment puisque les
délais les programmateurs de radio où
les maisons de disques sont incapables
de trouver des nouveaux artistes il faut
bien que le que le métier vives de
quelque chose que cette industrie marche
alors ils ont trouvé les compilations
c'est quand à monter un restaurant qui
s'appelle le chorus café alors jusqu'à
11 heures du soir
c'est un restaurant normal 11h bon ça
devient enchante crs de concerts sixties
tous les soirs vous chantez quoi la
jeune femme avoue jamais toute la nuit
quand même bien tranchante les sixties
mais le [ __ ] si c'était il fort pour
se replacer dans le contexte de 86 quand
j'ai créé mon restaurant
quand j'ai dit à certaines personnes de
ce métier je vais monter un restaurant
on va chanter des chansons des années 60
a répondu watts était fou ça fait
ringard les années 60 va et terrasses
personnes moi je sentais que le public
avait besoin de ça tu crois que tu vas
finir dans ce cabaret là dans ce
restaurant
je crois pourquoi je crois pas ce que
j'ai envie de faire d'autres choix que
faire quoi accueillir des disques
dis moi ton avis pourquoi t'es pas
devenu une énorme star pourquoi
finalement tu as déjà fait un tube les
boîtes à pas exploser complètement
parce que lorsque les journalistes de
france dimanche venez me voir je
refusais de monter des coups par cette
fois celui-ci médias parce que parce que
parce que je bois pas d'alcool je veux
dire je suis pas et ça veut pas dire que
ce soit un triste je viens mais je n'ai
pas tout ce côté puis qui favorise les
rencontres à 2 heures du matin et on va
sûrement vous maintenant que je suis pas
ça et
et n'est pas et sait plus quoi
non je crois que je crois que c'est
passé c'est pas grave
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
auditive abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux